as National addiction treatment week
approaches we are taking a look at the
severity of one of the biggest drugs
impacting our Valley and we're talking
about fentanyl tonight we look at one of
many local treatment facilities and how
they are fighting back
fentanyl is probably the biggest impact
of any drug in this in this Valley
Jonathan sprecker is the director of
nursing at Desert hope a drug and
alcohol treatment facility in Las Vegas
that he says is available to anyone
struggling who is ready to make a change
you don't go to rehab for three days and
come out and you're all better
um the brain chemistry
barely gets itself sorted in 90 days
fentanyl is an extremely strong
synthetic opioid made in a lab according
to the rehab facility it's used as a
cheap filler added to other illicit
drugs and counterfeit pills and has
played a major role in the country's
opioid overdose epidemic they tell us
fentanyl is mainly used for severe pain
and sold as patches or injections under
many of these brand names fantinellas
also known by other names in the street
I like most parents
desperately want to know why somebody's
going to do that last week the Southern
Nevada Health District alerting the
public of a rise in fentanyl deaths in
Clark County six suspected drug-related
overdoses during a 36-hour period last
year they reported 225 fentanyl deaths
and 191 the year prior it's become the
most common drug to mix with other with
other medications because it's so
inexpensive it's not only inexpensive
but it gives the person a high
well desert hope tells us the treatment
against fentanyl addiction begins with
the detox which can be very intense and
uncomfortable and also require immediate
medical attention now if you need help
check out 8newsnow.com for a list of
resources